[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist got
Chuck nice with me Chuck how you doing
man hey what's up Neil okay professional
comedian and actor yep acting like a
comedian acting like a comedian how's
that working for you yeah well you know
it's it's nice work if you can get
it so today what a topic today in long
overdue right it's our electrified
future yes it's on it's everybody's
thinking about it it's always in the
headlines yes what direct what path are
we going to take as
civilization in order to protect or to
survive to to survive to survive
basically let's be honest we're we we're
we're on the path to Doom right now if
we don't change and yeah well I we'll
we'll be here after climate change but
civilization won't that's the
differencea everything we've built that
we call civilization it's not clear how
that will survive it be everybody who
survives in Kevin
Cosner wa oh in Water World Water World
Water World okay nobody saw that movie
so that true it's an obscure reference
you
know so Chuck I carry some knowledge in
this field but for this kind of topic we
need expertise
like Centerline expertise so we comb the
landscape we found a PhD chemical
engineer named David rikou David welcome
to Star Talk thanks thanks for having me
very excellent you got a PhD in chemical
engineering specializing in electric
vehicles this is a thing wow and you're
a senior engineer in the clean
Transportation program of the Union of
concerned scientists I remember these
folks from way back deep Cold War era so
tell me what who they are and what you
all are doing today and presumably
you're still worrying about
nukes yeah no I mean that was the
Genesis about 50 years ago in in
Cambridge Massachusetts some um MIT
scientists concerned about the
militarization of science um especially
around uh nuclear weapons and um you
know and since that time you know we're
looking at how do we bring the voice of
Science in into into policy um not just
in terms of of weapons but now in terms
of climate change and and the
environment as well yeah you got a lot
to be concerned about there David that's
right you got you got a lot you got a
lot on your mind there you got a lot on
your mind but they are very concerned
people this is very
concerned bunch of guys in lab Cod
sitting around stroking their chins like
right right now Chuck I can see the
crossover point will they become when
they become the union of pissed-off
scientists that's what we need that is
what we need we need the union of pissed
off scientists I love it I I think we're
already there yeah oh yeah yeah there
you go there you
go but we already got the website so
we'll keep the name for
now so you focus on energy analysis
Transportation sustainability both of
things we need maximally in our modern
civilization and of course they overlap
and zero emission Vehicles nice so so
which true zero emission you you can't
start with the vehicle like right true
true zero emission we got to start with
the
grid where the energy is coming from
right that's that's okay but let's back
let's back up for a minute you
specialize in transportation what
fraction of our carbon footprint as
civilization comes from Transportation
at this point oh good one yeah so if if
you you look at the US um you look at
man-made sources of um climate pollution
uh transportation is the largest single
sector um it's over a quarter of all
human caused emissions in the US and um
when you look at Transportation over
half that comes from Passenger cars and
trucks so Passenger cars and trucks
alone are um more emissions than than
residential and commercial buildings put
together um and what about when you say
trucks you mean even even trucks for
distribution of goods we're talking
about uh the the pickup trucks and SUVs
in in our driveways not um so when we
talk about the half the emissions of
Transportation coming from Passenger
cars and trucks we're just talking about
um Regular old pickup trucks not
delivery trucks yeah everyday person
driving around is half of all emissions
that's that's insane that's half of all
Transportation emissions half of all
Transportation emissions yeah and the
other half comes from from what form of
transportation well that that's that's
sort of your L your larger trucks and
then um plane um shipping uh rail um but
but really um it's most of that that is
going to be your your larger trucks as
well so it's it's the onroad
transportation is really the the bulk of
of emissions as the senior uh member the
three of us the old fart uh I I I I have
deeper memories than you guys I remember
when air pollution simply meant the air
was
dirty so
now now the air is pretty clean all
things considered clean in terms of
transparency but we now think of CO2
byproduct of of combustion burning
fossil fuels as a pollutant of sorts uh
is that fair to say and and and do we
add that to what is
still polluting forces in our
environment enironment such as the
burning of
coal yeah so I mean you can look at in
terms of climate pollution and look I
mean there's because it's such a huge
part of our emissions there's no way to
like reduce our climate changing
emissions without doing something about
Passenger cars and trucks Abol there's
also the air pollution that comes from
these vehicles and they are cleaner than
than the vehicles of of 30 years ago of
my childhood yes okay but there're still
you know there's still you know air
pollution that is causing um you know
Health impacts um from the these
vehicles so um yeah a lot of it is is
coming from this uh fine particulate
matter um and so you want to and it's
particles that are it's PM 2.5 is a
technical term it's particles that are
smaller than 2.5 microns or micrometers
so Micron is a millionth of a meter if I
remember correctly is that correct okay
yeah yeah in just sort of context like
so if you have hair uh it's
about 70 if you have
hair 70
microns hypothetically if one had hair
on their head and could pull it out okay
I don't take that for granted but yes um
so that's about 70 uh microns the
average human hair and and so we're
talking about particles that are 2.5 and
smaller so really really tiny particles
um and these particles are coming from
the exhaust but in most cases they're
not coming directly it's it's actually
nitrogen oxides Vol to organic gases
combining the atmosphere making
combining with sunlight making two these
very tiny particles and then those
particles are going deep into your
lungs and that's coming because of how
small they are because of how so they
can they go past you know all all of the
filtering that you have naturally in
your nose in your and even in the top of
your lungs and they get deep into your
lungs they can even cross into the
bloodstream these are really um you know
that's where the most health impacts
from air pollution is coming from these
tiny particles and it's not when you say
air pollution from Vehicles everyone
thinks oh like a big rig like or a bus
belching you know a black cloud or uh
you know an old car that's that's
burning oil but even a new car that
doesn't look like it's putting out this
pollution
is leading to these really tiny
particles that that lead to asth heart
attacks so and and and the r the latest
research that I read Because I read a
lot about pollution for climate change
mostly but still is that
the previous thinking was that it it
triggered asthma but now the thinking is
that uh traffic pollution is causing
asthma particularly for what you just
said about the tiniest part of your
bronchioles I forget the name of it
alveoli or something like that um that's
where these particulates end up lodging
and uh so it it it actually causes
asthma yeah and it's it's not just
asthma I mean asthma is the most you
know like you think about bre breathing
in particles to your lungs you think
asthma and you think you know sort of
lung disease but it's it's also
cardiovascular disease it's low birth
weight um it's it's a lot of different
um
impacts Beyond just asthma but um you
know this is these are this is pollution
that that shortens people's lives yeah
so David civilization is killing us
that's what you're saying which no
concerned I love that he went no I'm not
saying that at all
no I I'm saying we we we we we're
exposed to this pollution some of us um
more than others uh and um and we can
get into that if you want but um but we
have now these options to to reduce that
and so that's where okay so one of the
options we've been told is switch over
to an electric car electric cars have
zero emissions at the car at the car
okay I get that I all right but they had
to build the car the car has weird
ingredients in it that regular car quote
you know the ice cars uh internal
combustion engine cars don't have and
that electricity is coming from
somewhere and I don't think it's all
from solar panels yet so tell me about
how green a green car really
is yeah so I mean that is something that
I've spent a lot of time doing analysis
around and so you know first you're the
right guy for this question
okay I am the right guy uh so first
let's look about like you talked about
the tailpipe pollution and that yeah so
a fully electric vehicle obviously no
tailpipe no tailpipe emissions that's
that's an easy one and but you because
you said hey that's maybe not the whole
story that means that it's a it's a zero
emission vehicle maybe at the car
tailpipe but not um overall and so what
we need to do then is we look at a life
cycle analysis so we need to do an
Apples to Apples comparison of the
looking at the whole process of getting
that car recharged and compare it to
refueling a gasoline car because that's
what we're trying to see if it's better
then right right that's the current Tech
technology and so that means for an
electric car going upstream and looking
at okay what are the emissions from
power plants um and then beyond that
like if it's a coal power plant a
natural gas power plant um what are the
emissions from getting that coal out of
the ground or getting that methane out
of the ground and getting it to um the
power plant and so you have to add up
all those emissions and then compare
them to the same thing for a gasoline
car obviously you're burning gasoline in
the car so we have those emissions that
are coming out of the tailpipe of CO2
but you also
have all the emissions of getting crude
oil out of the ground right um and then
getting it to a Refinery turning it into
gasoline getting that
gasoline um you know to a fueling
station and so there's all those steps
as well if you do that you find that
electric vehicles have you know not zero
total emissions but they have much lower
emissions than than a gasoline vehicle
so if you look at where EVS have been
sold in the
US um they have on average the average
EV has emissions about equal to an 88
mile per gallon gasoline car if that
exists that's amazing it's yeah and
that's that's based on the average EV if
you know and it does depend on where in
the country you are some places are
going to be cleaner than others right um
if you look in the average EV in like
the Northeast part of the us it's equal
to about 110 miles per gallon emission
gasoline car missions interesting to
think about it in that metric because
that would tell the auto
manufacturers keep using gas but make me
100 m mile per gallon car and then it's
it then you're
you're right neck with the electric car
achieved equilibrium yeah the the only
problem is you can't do that there's
like physics um I
mean that that py thing that old
physics God what physics have to do with
it come on David
physics yeah the maximum thermodynamic
efficiency of a of a combustion engine
and and it's pretty low it's very low I
mean we're getting you know we're pretty
close to you know you can get a um you
you can get a gasoline car that gets up
into the 50s mile per gallon range right
with with some of the the the
non-plug-in hybrids but you can't really
get further than that without doing you
know a significant ific size change in
the vehicle or or you know um I've got a
fast story which a little bit of an
off-ramp so uh we've had steam engines
like forever right so why did it take
until 1903 to make an airplane which is
just another engine but now it's flying
and the problem was to get enough power
out of a steam engine required a steam
engine that was so heavy you could never
get enough power to fly the damn thing
okay and so all the experiments people
were doing would say oh that'll never
work that'll never work it was not until
we had the internal combustion engine
that that the R Brothers and put that in
the airplane and now you it's much
lighter compared with the power output
and then you then you had airplanes
there it was so it's physics the physics
you can't you can't make a light enough
steam engine to do this with are are you
saying that the the moment that we go
fully electric we're going to have
flying cars
s did I didn't think I said that did I
did David I you didn't hear me say that
did you I
don't introducing the all electric Ford
Mustang Mach SUV Ford is electrifying
its icons to keep the sole of driving
alive while shifting towards an electric
vehicle future the Mustang Mach e is an
SUV with the Bold style of a Mustang
which means you can make a bold
statement and still be practical the
2023 Mustang Mach e GT performance
Edition SUV achieves 0 to 60 miles per
hour in 3.5 seconds it's an EV with
exhilarating torque and available
features like electric all-wheel drive
and a drive mode called unbridled it has
room for you your people and your things
with five seats and a front otherwise
known as a front trunk experience the
freedom and Thrill of the drive while
knowing your needs can still be met
learn more about the all electric Ford
Mustang Mach SUV at
ford.com
svsm due to high demand and Global
Supply Chain constraints some models
trims and features may not be available
or may be subject to change check with
your local dealer for current
information for the 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds Ford test data is based on a
typical industry methodology using one
foot roll out your results May Vary so
okay so that's a fascinating way to
compare that now what about uh you
haven't mentioned access to the rare uh
metals or other components of not only
the battery but also the the significant
Computing load that an electric car
carries yeah so we also looked at sort
of what are the emissions from from
building an electric vehicle because as
you said like there are the emissions
involved in making that battery and so
when you look at manufacturing a
gasoline vehicle manufacturing a
electric vehicle the uh emissions for
building that electric vehicle for for
global warming emissions are higher and
um so there there's sort of this this um
emissions deficit but you pay off that
debt over the about yeah in about uh it
depends on whether you're looking at a
pickup truck or or a car and depending
on where you are but on average for a
pickup truck in about a year and a half
of driving and about two years of
driving for for a car well um and so
overall if you take in both the driving
and the manufacturer of the vehicle if
you compare an electric pickup truck to
to a gasoline pickup truck it's it's
less than half the total um global
warming emissions even when you consider
the manufacturing of the battery so okay
so now what so now that's assuming that
the electric grid is being fed by
traditional coal or or or gas right so
if you can have an electrical grid that
is green either from tidal or wind or
solar and because I I tell you I had
this moment some years ago 20 years ago
I was driving an electric car test drive
driving electric car and I did it at a
power station and one of the the I was
going to call spigots but no but one of
the the the stanions at the power
station connected to their nuclear plant
and so we charged up this car from the
nuclear plant and I drove around and I I
felt so zero carbon footprint in that
moment it was it was it was a remarkable
feeling in that moment I said wow not a
single charcoal briette was harmed in
this not a single gallon of gasoline was
used to to make this happen yeah I mean
that's a great point because um you know
all the analysis I've done is based on
sort of historical data so the most
recent data I could get from the EPA
from um 2021 so we're we're kind of
looking back now a couple years uh when
we do this analysis and um you know that
grid is getting cleaner over time at
Union concerned scientists we've been
doing this analysis now for for over 10
years when we first did this analysis it
the the results were a little more mixed
you know because we had almost half the
power in you know in 2009 almost half
the power in the US coming from coal
that's now down below 20% right U power
coming from coal um you know renew uh
Renewables are now higher um than than
coal in the US so we're making this
transition and those cars are getting
cleaned up and the cool thing about
electric cars is that um you know you if
you buy a car you know five years ago
and the grid gets cleaner that means the
emissions are going down over time for
that even for your car yeah for your car
so it's not just like you know if you
want to get a gasoline car that's more
efficient that has fewer emissions you
have to go out and get a new car that's
you know has a higher MPG your electric
car is going to be plugging into the
same plug but it's going to be getting
cleaner as we clean
those e are getting cleaner that's
amazing yeah there's a book I read
called Turning oil into salt and I
forgot the the two authors co-authors of
that where that that made a fascinating
point which was you have a car that
requires oil products so gasoline it'll
only run on
gasoline so wherever your oil comes from
in the world you know about it because
it's it's a strategic commodity salt
used to be a strategic commodity because
it was the only way you could preserve
foods from one Harvest into the next
spring and so your life depended on
knowing where the salt come from and how
much it cost today do you know how much
your salt costs do you even care do you
know where it comes from you don't know
and you don't care because we have 12
other ways to preserve your food
Refrigeration freezing canning um it
goes on and on and salt is like a one of
a dozen or more so the thesis of the
book was if you have a car that does not
depend on gasoline that could run on 30
different types of
fuel then the gasoline is no longer a
strategic commodity it's just has to
compete with 30 other Commodities well
how big an engine do you have to have so
you can put anything in it and have it
still run Oh no just make an electric
car plug it into the wall and on the
other side of that plug
is the sources the multiple sources of
energy that are competing with each
other there's an Open Marketplace our
demands what they Supply and so so an
electric car does run on 25 different
sources of fuel is that a fair
understanding of this David yeah I mean
that is one of the huge advantages that
you can make electricity from cleaner
sources and we can make that transition
and it doesn't mean you know your
electric vehicle still plugs into the
same Outlet the two authors there I've
got an K and Gale l so they're the two
authors of that of that book turning oil
into salt I thought it was a brilliant
thesis there yeah so so David so David
are you at odds with oil companies here
why don't they just convert to green or
is that what they're already doing oh
they're they're with David I'll tell you
that
much no no they must know something
because they changed their names they're
not oil companies anymore they're energy
companies that's right is the first step
but greenwashing that's greenwashing
well I know but maybe it's maybe it's
real no I mean I I I don't think any of
the petroleum companies are interested
in in accelerating this transition to
electric vehicles uh I mean they you
know I think that you know at one point
it was you know that these these
electric vehicles can't work nobody's
going to want them nobody can use them
um I think now the the opponents of
electric vehicles are more in the mode
of yes yes yes we'll make this
transition but let's just do it as
slowly as possible uh you know we have
we have 30 years of oil that we'd like
to um now it's even more than
that or whatever and like fracking if
fracking goes goes unchecked it's more
than that right yeah but then after
after we do that then yeah then we we'll
do it yeah and we'll all be dead but
guess what I don't know who we're gonna
s to you but we'll just we'll just be
living in a hotter less hospitable world
that um and wait wait David so so let me
ask let me come at this another way I I
just try to stay open here to not so
open that my brain spill out but I want
to just make sure all options are
covered you go back 120 years there were
horses everywhere uh i' see the old
pictures in New York City the horses
everywhere HSE drawn carriages and cabs
and everything and this horse poop
everywhere manure and so the city stank
and there flies and they and there were
no supermarkets then a lot of food
Merchants were just on the street so the
Flies were in the food and when I grew
up you didn't complain if flies were
everywhere because that's just how
everything was even in the deli there
flies all all right you didn't want the
Flies but you lived with them you get
rid of the manure okay then you get rid
of most of the Flies so how you gonna
get rid of the manure well you can put
something in the H's feet so maybe the
Flies don't like it you put less bulk in
there so they poop less all these
Solutions and the solution really was
the
car okay but no one was saying let's
let's invent a car so that we don't have
flies on my deli sandwich it was there
was just progress so I recently saw a a
a a uh a news brief on this startup
company that wants to pull CO2 out of
the atmosphere they they they have this
this array this like phased array of the
raw ingredients that has everything
except CO2 to make
Limestone and they blow the air across
it that this substance this powdery
substance grabs the CO2 and makes
Limestone and then they take the
Limestone and bury it into the Earth
these would be CO2 scrubbers I think we
call them and if one of these was at
every Power Plant then we could
control in in a in an act of
geoengineering control the amount of CO2
in the atmosphere and if we did that and
if we could do it then you can burn as
much oil as you wanted until there's not
a drop left and and it will have no
effect on climate change provided we
this doesn't run away from us so is
there any thinking along those lines
well I think what's a lot cheaper and
easier is not putting the CO2 in the ATM
the atmosphere in the then trying to
trying to pull it out the the the best
thing you can do is just avoid it allog
together if you can walk bike take
transit um take your electric bicycle
whatever that's the best thing you can
do the second best thing is is to is to
not not burn the gasoline um so really
the solution to the uh um anecdote that
you gave NE is get rid of the
horses that's that's the the 2 Century
version version of that just get rid of
it so yeah yeah it makes sense I and and
well wa but David David David I I live
in the in the real world here and I
interact with the public daily through
my social media platforms and I care
about how they think because I knowing
that enables me to communicate more
effectively all right so that my message
is received with receptors that I know
lives within them and what I can tell
you without hesitation is there's always
some fraction of the population that's
ready to change and modify their
behavior and do whatever they got to do
for the good of the earth and then
there's the rest of everybody that says
I don't want to change a damn thing I
feel change
and so for example go back 150 years we
were still slaughtering uh whales for
whale oil whale oil right to burn our
lamps and everything and the blubber was
highly valuable and there were people
that didn't want to kill kill these
majestic creatures were they successful
not really yes we stopped killing whales
but not really because they're saying no
we stopped killing whales because we
found oil in the ground okay we found
oil in the ground to burn so so once
again things changed because not because
you got billions of people to change
their behavior but because some form of
Discovery technology um some some
addition to our civilization did not
require you to change your behavior you
are right in that this you know we it's
a an amazing amount of change in a
really short period of time look if if
you look 15 years ago the only people
that had electric cars were people that
basically had to make their own electric
cars no they were people who played golf
people who played
golf but uh well there's there's a few
people out there making their own like
electric cars in their
garage yeah and then um and if you look
at maybe like 10 years ago you really
had to go out of your way to get an
electric car there was only a few
available um they some of them weren't
really great at being a car uh and you
had to go out of your way to do it and
there weren't there weren't a whole lot
of them sold if you look at today we got
in California a TW over 25% of new cars
are plug in electric vehicles and all
yeah uh and we so we are getting we are
getting past the early adopters we're
starting to get into um you know really
into the mainstream at least in parts of
the US um and that David just just so
you know don't be so surprised because
back to the horses New York City went
from all horses in
1905 to basically all cars in 1920 you
couldn't give away a horse 15 years
later and we civilization was built
literally and fig figuratively on the
backs of horses for thousands of years
and they were gone within 15 years and
that's got to be a bigger transition for
that that was surely a bigger transition
for anybody around at the turn of that
Century than going from combustion
engine to electric cars today it's for
the same reason though cars are so much
better than horses that's all there was
to it they're just so much better and I
think the same thing will happen with
electric vehicles electric vehicles are
just so much better than combustion
engines except for the one concern that
most people have and that is range
anxiety but for the average driving
needs of most that's a solvable problem
that's very solvable and it's it's just
so much
better David are you are you concerned
do I get to use that word in this way
are you concerned about people's range
anxiety about whether they're going to
run out of battery and there's no place
to refill and then they're stranded on
the road
you they can't even they can't even walk
to the nearest station with a can gas
station and get a can of gas get and
bring the can of gas back excuse me do
you have a 25 mile long
[Laughter]
cord uh I
mean there that the issue of like where
do you charge for most of the people
buying electric car today it's pretty
simple you charge in your driveway or
your garage
um and you you know okay so instead of
filling up in in the road you fill up at
home yeah yeah and so that that's part
of the thing is that you don't you know
if you're driving a lot of the cars
right now have over 200 mile range so
you're for most of your driving everyday
driving you're commuting to work or you
know visiting for me visiting family in
in the Bay Area like it's it's not a
really a question of where do you charge
I charge in the garage and then you know
if if it if it's low on Range I plug it
in and the next morning it's full good
to uh it's really simple um now we do
need those public charging stations so
you can take those longer trips easily
or if you don't have the the the ability
to charge at home um and so that's
something that is is happening right now
is building out that that that charging
infrastructure so that more people can
use it so I'm gonna add to this when I
was growing up uh in we saw a lot of
plays I grew up in New York City Play
Bill always had multiple ads for cars
and they always showed people driving on
an open road and it's like take a trip
today go take a drive and and it's
Sunday take a drive and I and I just
thought that was the natural order of
the universe that when you got a car you
just found a place to drive to the car
wasn't a utility it was an expression of
your freedom
and I don't see that happening anymore I
don't people say let's take a drive for
100 miles and look at the scenery and
then come back I don't see your maybe
it's still happening I don't see it it
could be that this range anxiety is a
leftover from people who were thinking
about taking a 200 mile car trip but
today just wouldn't do that anymore you
you get on Zoom and talk to people you
know what are you doing that for what's
the need so you got to be in the car
with your family come on is that it
okay so David I maybe there's fewer
trips that are even necessary I mean
look people buy an electric car they
want to be able to see like hey can I
get from Oakland to to Boston you know
can I drive there it's like you know are
there enough charging space not that
they ever did before okay go on or not
that they ever will right if I need to
get the Boston I'm probably gonna go to
the airport um
and uh and I don't want to have to drive
for for days on end to do that but you
know I think that people want to be able
to see that end it's something that you
know this is a transition that that is
you know we are still on the first steps
of this transition and and we are there
are there's Federal funding for in the
bipartisan infrastructure law over 7
billion to build out charging stations
um in the US um a lot of the car compan
compan are investing in charging uh
infrastructure to make sure that you can
make all of those trips um now it's
going to be a little bit different than
a gasoline car you might have to do a
little bit of like planning or or at
least see like where the charging
stations are apps for that now that I
mean I have an I have an electric car
it's an app it tells me when I get in
the car the first thing it says is where
I can go charge if I need why don't the
why don't the traditional convenient
Marts all have electric charging
stations or do they I haven't noticed
that
the charging stations tend to be in
other
places I mean it's it's it's a there are
different there's different reasons why
different charging stations are in
different places and it depends on who's
buying the charging station whether it's
a car company
or for-profit uh you know thirdparty
charging company but I think part of it
is just that like it is going to take a
just a different slightly different
mindset and we are people that have
where the norm is the gasoline car and
the the electric vehicle is the weird
thing and I have to do research I have
to figure it out okay like if you go you
know like if we go to if we went to a
cardial ship and said like I'd like to
buy a gasoline car they wouldn't spend
time telling me well here's how you
refuel it like you know here's how
it here's the map of gas stations for
you yes but I'm you know if I was if I
was maybe not an expert on EVs and going
to I might have those questions right so
it's a different mindset like my
daughter is 18 she learned how to drive
on electric car that is the normal for
her I when she was going she went off to
college this uh this fall and there are
rental cars on her campus and I was like
oh my gosh do you know how to refuel a
gasoline car she said no no I I had we
had to go to a gas station and and like
okay here's you know you take the you
take the nozzle out you put here you
here's how you do it and and you know
that is just you know plus you don't
want her to be one of those people who
likes the smell of gasoline you know
there's some people who are those people
I don't know who those people are but
they exist for sure I mean I know for I
mean also for an 18-year-old like uh
instead of spending $70 at a gas station
charging at home every day every night
is is a great is a great deal big big
deal plus often the the the electric
rates are lower at night so it's very
natural PL in your car hours much
cheaper at night which is why you got to
plug in plug in at night charge
overnight do yeah in any event it's
going to be cheaper than than gasoline
what is the compatibility among
different charging stations with the
cars people buy because we all the gas
nozzles they match up no matter what
brand of car it is so did we have this
issue coming into this brand new
Marketplace yeah so most most of the
charges at home were were the same type
uh when we look at Chargers though for
the fast charging we had Essen three
different plugs um one plug that the
Japanese car companies were using one
that the US and the European car
companies were using and then one that
Tesla was using um now pretty much all
cars and all manufacturers from 2025 and
onwards have said they're going to use
the North American charging standard as
the one plug so right now there's still
this diversity of plugs but going
forward that's all going to standardize
to one fast charging plug okay that's
that's that's very hopeful I know we're
still in the early days of this
Marketplace but right now if you compare
the price of an electric car to that of
an internal combustion there's a very
big gap there so is are electric cars a
rich people's game and will that ever
change I mean as we're as we're getting
more and more models out there we're
going to see both you know luxury cars
and we're going to see more recently
priced uh electric vehicles one thing
that is going to help is that the uh
Federal um tax credit um has is is going
to make that initial cost of the the
electric vehicle more competitive with a
gasoline vehicle um starting in in
January of
2024 um a lot of car companies are going
to be able to offer that at the
dealership so you don't have to wait for
your tax return you're just going to get
that um just as as as part of the you
know taking off the sale price so this
is the federal government basically
investing in in the stability of its own
Energy Future so you foresee a in in the
near future not only marketing
incentives brought by by federal
government but also the an overall drop
in price do you foresee that yeah we're
seeing battery prices come down and I
mean they've they've dropped dramtic
dramatically in the last decade um and I
think that's still going to happen as we
start building more B batteries um have
that price of the batteries come down
which makes the price of electric
vehicle come down the other part it is
that The Upfront cost of these electric
vehicles is higher but the cost of
recharging these vehicles is much lower
than buying gasoline so on net um you're
going to be able to have a total cost of
ownership that's less um but it is and L
maintenance and repair of course yeah
maintenance and repair yeah no oil
changes for the fully electric vehicles
no spark plugs um it's you know it's a
pretty simple um electric motor um so
there's not really much maintenance you
know you still have to change the tires
um
but you got to put the windshield wiper
fluid in but that's about it
okay uh is there still talk of possibly
swapping out a battery so that you don't
have to wait the duration of time
because not all charging stations are
are are created equal right depends on
the voltage and as I understand it David
the charging rate goes as the square of
the voltage right and so so uh if I
understand that correctly so you want as
high a voltage charging station as
possible and then it goes rapidly maybe
in the time it takes you to have a cup
of coffee it's great but to the extent
that those are not available you can't
on a trip say I got to sit here for two
hours in charge while I twiddle my
thumbs I i' I I would have finished my
cup of coffee in 15 minutes so what is
do you guys have a response to that on
the grid yeah yeah so on the latest
charging stations go up to to
350 350 kilowatts um and the the the
there's also a part of it that's
dependent on the car so some of the cars
are built around an 800 volt
architecture that can accept um the
maximum rate of charge and so those cars
are cars that you can go from say 20%
charge to 80% charge in less than 20
minutes um and so that is that's really
all you need right that's all you need
yeah and that is the case where like hey
like if you been driving for two or
three hours yeah like it's not bad to
take a a 15 minute or 20 minute stop
stretch your legs get a cup of coffee
Etc and so I think I think that is part
of it is that you know as we look into
the future more and more the cars are
going to be capable of doing those
faster charges where it's yeah it's
going to be a little bit longer than it
than um than filling up with gasoline I
don't know when I when I take road trips
with with with my kids uh you know the
the the the the gasoline stop is not the
one that that extends my my trip it's
the it's the having to stop for the
bathroom having to stop for snacks right
then stopping for the bathroom again and
so that those are the stops yeah and we
we talking about going 400 miles or
something then you know you're probably
gonna make a stop anyway yeah maybe too
and like you said the fast Chargers are
amazing they they charge you like like
you said from first of all you're never
going to zero because the the car won't
let you it the app tells you hey man you
got to go here and charge and secondly
so you're down around 20% you're going
up to 80% you know and sometimes even
and it takes about 20 not even 20
minutes the last time I did it on a 350
kilowatt charger uh it took me n 18
minutes exactly and I went to 92% I
remember and the only reason I stopped
is because some guy pulled up to the
charging station and he was looking at
at me like you dick I can't believe
you're at the 350 charging station so I
can see he wanted that charging station
because there was only one 350 kilowatt
Char the future of street fights exactly
access to the high so I saw him about to
park and I wait I motioned to him I was
like yo man I'm gonna leave and I just
stopped so you know I mean but at some
point you won't have that at some point
I I Envision a time and maybe it's me
just being super optimistic but I
envision time where municipalities will
invest in charging stations so instead
of parking meters you'll plug in you'll
pay your parking meter and a charging
fee and the and the city will make money
that way you know I could totally see
that happening stop trying to give
advice for how New York City can get
more parking fees I that's true what do
me stop that stop okay um Dave we got to
sort of land This Plane here I got over
question I know no way I know David
David uh can the
grid handle 100% electric cars the
electrical grid the power grid yeah it
it will be able to if we do this right
and that's the sort of that the next
that doesn't sound very encouraging we
will maybe if we sort of might be able
to because that's because because be
careful what we wish for you want
everybody to have electric cars you have
electric cars now we have to have brown
outs or blackouts because the electric
car is definitely drawing more power
than my air conditioner did in the
summer right when they're telling me to
to to to unplug stuff because the power
grid can't handle it what Assurance do I
have that on the other side of that
equation on the other side of the plug
the power is going to be there for
everybody if everybody switches
over I mean that's a great example
because your air conditioner I mean you
need it when you need it right right
like you you need it at maybe at at 400m
on on a summer day yeah um and and you
don't you're not really interested in
changing that to to using it at 4 AM
maybe right um and so that is the thing
is that most EVS are going to be parked
for over 20 hours a day maybe 23 hours a
day um and they're probably going to
actually act even at home actively
charge for maybe two or three hours even
if you've been driving
around and so so it spreads it spreads
that out okay if we can be smart about
when those cars are being charged like
you only if you only need to charge for
two hours um you know it doesn't need to
be at the same time than your that your
air conditioner okay so so I'm making
this up but the power company could then
strategically price hour by hour what
your fees are forcing people to respond
to save money by charging their cars at
different times of day yeah I just got
an email today from from Marine clean
electricity that that had an offer that
if you said okay I need if you have use
their app and say okay I need to have my
car fully charged by 7 am but you get
but you the power company get to pick
when they would give you a rebate
because that way they could money back
they could pick and the great thing is
that that lets you actually get more
Renewables on the grid because hey look
if there's more wind power or if it's
during the day like you know it's it's
10:00 a.m. in the morning and air
conditioners haven't kicked on yet but
we have lots of solar power charge the
vehicle's then oh so you can sync up
Renewables and with the with a source of
power that it is without having to store
it you can just distribute it through
the 24-hour cycle that's brilliant yeah
it's like obvious but completely
brilliant I was going to say at some
point the grid will be smart enough
won't it to to actually
can uh kind of almost as a collaboration
with the homeowner to tell you hey you
know or or to look at patterns and find
for you the best time to do
everything yeah and I think that's where
we need to go it's but it's going to
require that the car companies it's
going to require the utilities The
Regulators all sort of working together
me right now it's not an issue but we
want to lay the foundation so that when
we do get all those electric vehicles
out there that this is all worked out
and we're not trying to figure it out on
the back end right so have we solved
this other than just batteries is there
a more inventive storage mechanism for
daytime solar power or or does it have
to be used as it gets
generated I mean I think the easiest
thing is that if we can use it when it's
available that is the best thing and
that's where EVS both in passenger
vehicles Al also larger vehicles uh
trucks school buses are a great example
because they only get used usually like
twice a day and the rest of the time
they could be sitting there being
charged the other thing that we can do
is that if everyone has a big battery in
their driveway or or garage is that we
could even go one step further instead
of just controlling when they charge we
could have them send power back to the
grid when there is the peak load um so
that is the other step uh is sort of not
just controlling when they charge but
can they actually power back or if
there's a power outage can they power a
home or even help power a neighborhood
um this all falls under vehicle to grid
integration and it is okay incredibly
important thing that is is that's
awesome where we're just starting to
sort of figure out the policies to make
that happen and real quick is there any
any plans to have like photov voltaic
skins on a car so that the car itself
becomes a recharging
Source in the
daytime car stranded at night okay but
okay yeah yeah there are people that
have looked into that there there's a
few models that have have looked into
doing that but in general it's hard to
get enough uh you don't have enough area
to really recharge car you need more
area and also the other thing is you
have to be parked somewhere that is um
Sunny where you can use that and and and
it might not necessarily be at the right
angle whereas if you have panels on the
ground or on a roof you you can angle
them correctly and they're going to get
sun when it's sunny um so I think that
is the problem yeah you can make a solar
powered car it's been done they I think
they had a race in Australia like like
decades ago uh where they did that um
but it involved having like one person
laying down in this very flat
aerodynamic car
and so maybe not um practical for for
for years not ready for prime time yet
yes
okay guys we got to close this out David
how do we find you the union of
concerned scientists online where what's
your the website there yeah we are at
www.s
usa.org
ucsusa Does it include do you
collaborate with uh other other
countries yeah most of our work is is
based in the us but we definitely you
know have have some work uh in terms of
like the international climate work
David this has been delightfully
informative and I'm glad to know that
you and others of your brethren exist in
this world being of course concerned
about and you didn't sound too pissed
off you're still in the realm of concern
the day you get pissed off call us back
we'll give you platform for that right
we can and we can talk some more uh and
you probably have other scientists we
might try to Plum the depth of expertise
among your ranks there that'll be fun to
bring people on to talk about other
issues that concern the union of
concerned scientists so Dr Routh thanks
for being on Star Talk thanks for having
me it was pleasure it's all right Chuck
good to have you man always a pleasure
all right this has been Star Talk uh a
union of concerned scientists Edition
telling us about the future of an
electrified World Neil degrass Tyson as
always bidding you to keep looking
[Music]
up